THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANCHORS
ANGLE.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING
PHENOMENON.
PERSON A COMPETES FOR SOMETHING
REALLY BIG.
AND THEN COMES UP SHORT.
IN THIS HYPOTHETICAL CONTEST,
ONLY, OF COURSE, ONE SIDE WINS,
AND PERSON A IS ON THE LOSING
SIDE.
AND YET AFTER SUFFERING A DEFEAT
THEM A PERSON A EMERGES MORE
ARROGANT AND MORE SELF-ASSURED
THAN EVER BEFORE.
PROCLAIMING THAT THEY
HAD CERTAIN
THINGS HAPPENED IT DIFFERENTLY,
HE OR SHE INDEED WOULD HAVE WON.
AND PERSON?
WE SEE VERY LITTLE
INTROSPECTION.
ZERO HUMILITY.
AND FRANKLY, ZERO LOGIC.
PERHAPS THE MOST DISTURBING IN
THIS SCENARIO IS WHEN PERSON A
TRY TO USE HIS OR HER LOSS AS A
SELLING POINT.
FOUR PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR WHO
FIT THE MOLD IN RECENT WEEKS
COME TO MIND.
FIRST UP, TALLAHASSEE
MAYOR ANDREW GILLUM.
REMEMBER?
HE LOST HIS BID TO GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA.
HE COULDN'T BEAT RON DeSANTIS,
BUT NOW HE FANCIES HIMSELF AS
THE GREAT TRUMP SLAYER OF
FLORIDA.
>> WE ARE GOING TO COMMIT
OURSELVES TO REGISTERING AND
ENGAGING 1 MILLION VOTERS
BETWEEN NOW AND 2020s
PRESIDENTIAL PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
WE CAN DENY DONALD TRUMP A
SECOND TERM.
I'VE GOT TO ADMIT.
I'M SURE IT'S MORE FUN FOR SOME
OF THOSE OUT THERE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE HARD WORK OF
DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: REMEMBER, HE COULD
BE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, YOU
KNOW, BUT HE'S DECIDED TO DO THE
REALLY HARD STUFF.
I HAVE A QUESTION, WHY DO THE
DEMOCRATS LISTEN TO HIM ON
ANYTHING LIKE ME HE'S A LOSER.
WHY SHOULD ANYONE LISTEN TO HIM.
HE IS A SELF-APPOINTED SPOKESMAN
FOR THE LOSERS GRIEVANCE CULTURE
THAT WEAVE UP
DEVELOPED HERE.
WITH A COMPLIANT MEDIA WORKING
HAND IN GLOB, ELEVATING THEIR
MESSAGE, THE STATUTE, THE LOSERS
WOULDN'T FEEL SO EMBOLDENED.
BUT, BOY, DO THEY?
CONSIDER ARROGANT LOSER NUMBER
TWO HE READ STACY ABRAMS, WHO
LOST HER RACE FOR GOVERNOR TO
BRIAN KEMP IN GEORGIA.
REMEMBER, SHE DIDN'T LOSE.
THEY TOOK IT FROM HER.
>> CITIZENS TRIED TO EXERCISE
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND
WERE STILL DENIED THE ABILITY TO
ELECT THEIR LEADERS.
UNDER THE WATCH OF THE NOW
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
SECRETARY OF STATE, DEMOCRACY
FAILED TO GEORGIA.
SO LET'S BE CLEAR.
THIS IS NOT A SPEECH OF
CONCESSION.
>> OKAY.
SHE DOESN'T AND THE SEED.
THAT'S GRACIOUS.
NEVER ONCE CALLED OUT FOR HER
SHAMELESS RACIAL FEARMONGERING.
THEY HAVE A FUTURE IN SOME POINT
AGAIN IN POLITICS.
BUT SHE ACTS LIKE SHE OWNS THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRAT FIELD FOR 2020.
WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT?
SHE SCOFFED AT THE NOTION PUSHED
BY THE NASCENT FIGHTING CAMPAIGN
OF BEING UNCLE JOE'S
VICE PRESIDENTIAL RUNNING MATE.
>> I DO NOT THINK YOU RUN FOR
SECOND PLACE.
I'M GOING TO ENTER THE PRIMARY,
I'M GOING TO ENTER THE PRIMARY.
IF I DON'T I AM MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THE BEST DEMOCRAT BECOMES A
NOMINEE AND WHOEVER WINS THE
PRIMARY THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT
PERSON GETS ELECTED IN 2020.
>> Laura: ENTER THE PRIMARY?
HELLO, YOU LOST THE GOVERNOR'S
RACE.
I MEAN, YOU AND YOUR OPPONENT
MADE HISTORY MAKING MORE THAN
$100 MILLION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
RACE AND COULDN'T PULL OUT THE
VICTORY.
I MEAN, IT HAPPENS.
BUT YOU THINK YOU CALL THE SHOT
SHOTS?
>> RUNNING IN A PRIMARY TO BE
VICE PRESIDENT IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN ELECTED
BY THE PARTY TO BE THE NOMINEE,
ASKING YOU TO SERVE AS A
PARTNER.
I AM OPEN TO ALL OPTIONS.
>> Laura: SO AMAZING.
THE CHUTZPAH.
I'M SURE SHE'S OPEN TO ALL
OPTIONS.
HERE IS OUR THIRD LOSER, BETO
O'ROURKE.
HE'S TREATED LIKE THE CROWN
PRINCE OF TEXAS DESPITE
SUFFERING A SIGNIFICANT DEFEAT
AT THE HANDS OF TED CRUZ IN THE
TEXAS SENATE RACE.
REMEMBER, HE HAD THE WHOLE
LANDSCAPE OF THE MEDIA BEHIND
HIM, SPENT ALL THIS MONEY, BUT
HE HAS ISSUES GRASPING REALITY.
>> YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IN
MY OPINION BEYOND THE SHADOW OF
A DOUBT SOUGHT TO OR HAM
HANDEDLY COLLUDE WITH THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT, A FOREIGN
POWER, TO UNDERMINED AND
INFLUENCE OUR ELECTION.
>> Laura: THAT WAS SATURDAY!
CUCKOO FOR COCOA PUFFS.
GOOD LUCK ADVANCING THE
COLLUSION NARRATIVE NOW, ROBERT
FRANCIS.
AND OUR LAST LOSER?
TRYING TO CLAIM VICTORY?
IS JUST A SMALL
IT  IS JUSSIE SMOLLET THERE HE A
IT  IS JUSSIE SMOLLET THERE HE E
IT  IS JUSSIE SMOLLET THERE HE D
A HATE CRIME, SINCE CHICAGO PD
IN TWO WEEKS OF INVESTIGATION,
AND HE LIKELY FRIGHTENED
MINORITIES CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RACIAL ATMOSPHERE IN AMERICA.
HIS ACTIONS AND THE FOLLOW-UP
WERE UTTERLY DESPICABLE.
BUT HE'S BEEN TAUGHT TO WIN BY
DOING WHAT?
PLAYING THE VICTIM, OF COURSE.
WHICH IS WHAT HE DID ON TUESDAY.
>> I'VE BEEN TRUTHFUL AND
CONSISTENT ON EVERY SINGLE LEVEL
SINCE DAY ONE.
I WILL NOT BE MY MOTHER'S SON IF
I WAS CAPABLE OF ONE DROP OF
WHAT I WAS ACCUSED OF.
THIS HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TIME.
>> Laura: 'S LAWYER GOES ON TO
LEAVE OPEN THE POSSIBILITY THAT
JUSSIE WOULD COLLECT MONEY
IN A LAWSUIT AGAINST CHICAGO PD.
>> WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS HE
WANTS HIS CAREER AND LIFE BACK.
HE DID NOT ASK FOR ANY OF THIS.
HE WAS A VICTIM OF A CRIME.
>> Laura: AT SOME POINT, CAN
LAWYERS BE SANCTIONED FOR SAYING
SOMETHING THAT'S BLATANTLY FALSE
ON NATIONAL TELEVISION PUTTS AND
WHAT DOES THE NAACP DO TO
REWARD CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR?
OF COURSE THEY NOMINATE HIM FOR
ANOTHER NAACP AWARD, OF COURSE.
>> I HOPE HE'S HERE.
I HOPE HE WINS.
I HOPE EVERYONE WINS.
IT'S A BIG EVENT.
AND, YOU KNOW, I'M GLAD
EVERYTHING IS WORKED OUT FOR
HIM.
>> Laura: HERE'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THERE IS THIS IMPULSE TO SHOWER
LOSERS WITH ACCOLADES AND
IMPORTANCE WHEN THE LOSERS ARE
ANTI-TRUMP.
IF YOU ARE PRO TRUMP AND YOU
LOSE, YOU HAVE TO GET OVER IT
AND GET OUT OF THE WAY.
EXCEPT THE RESULTS.
NOT SO ON THE OTHER SIDE.
IN HOLLYWOOD, THE NEWS MEDIA
PRINT JOURNALIST, IF YOU ARE
ANTI-TRUMP, WE    WE WILL WORK
OVERTIME TO REWRITE YOUR
NARRATIVE FOR YOU.
REMEMBER," HOME ALONE," REMEMBER
WHEN KEVIN McALLISTER TOOK ON
THE BAD GUYS?
>> OKAY, KID!
GIVE IT TO ME!
[CLONK]
>> DIRECT HIT!
>> Laura: IT WAS NEVER THE
FAULT OF THE BANDITS.
THE BLAME WAS SOLELY ON THE POOR
KID WHOSE PARENTS LEFT HIM HOME
ALONE.
MY FRIENDS, IF YOU WANT TO
REMAKE AMERICA FROM SUITS TO
NUTS OR ROB SOME HOUSES AROUND
CHRISTMAS TIME, YOU DON'T HAVE
TIME FOR CORROBORATING OR
CHANGING YOUR TECHNIQUE.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
YOU DOUBLE DOWN ON FAILURE.
YOU ACT LIKE YOU WILL MAKE BIG
AND WON THE LOTTO.
YOU BLAME YOUR LOSS AND SOMEONE
ELSE.
VERY, VERY MATURE.
NO OTHER PROFESSION TREATS THIS
THE SAME WAY, BUT IN POLITICS
REALITY IS OFTEN SUSPENDED BUT
YOU DON'T DESERVE ANYTHING,
THOUGH.
RIGHT?
WE WERE TOLD YOU NEED TO EARN
IT.
ALL THOSE PARENTS WHO BRIBE
THEIR KIDS A POSITIVE WAY INTO
COLLEGE THOUGHT THEIR KIDS
DESERVE TO GO TO YALE, USC,
WAKE FOREST, SANFORD.
IT'S JUST THAT THE SYSTEM WAS
SCREWED UP, SO THEY DECIDED TO
GAME THE SYSTEM.
IN ULTIMATELY THE FRAUD WAS
DISCOVERED.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SHARPER THAN THE LEFT GIVES THEM
CREDIT FOR.
I DON'T THINK THEY LIKE ALL THIS
RADICALISM, NOR THE ENTITLEMENT
MENTALITY THAT SEEMS TO BE
INFECTING ALL RACES, ALL
ETHNICITIES TODAY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT BASIC FAIRNESS
BID BASIC STANDARDS OF DECENCY.
COMMON SENSE.
NOT FANATICAL EFFORT TO
DECONSTRUCT AMERICA AND
RECONSTRUCT HER INTO WHAT TEDDY
ROOSEVELT CALLED "THE POLYGLOT
BOARDINGHOUSE."
BEING A LOSER MEANS YOU CAN'T
WIN AGAIN.
NOT SAYING THAT.
REAGAN SHOWED US THAT AFTER HE
LOST IN '76, CAME BACK IN 1980.
THE REST IS HISTORY.
ALSO DOESN'T MEAN YOU SHOULD
EXPECT THE REST OF US TO BOW
DOWN AT YOUR EVERY WORD JUST
BECAUSE YOU SAY THERE WASN'T
ENOUGH BREATHLESS ABOUT HOW MUCH
YOU DON'T LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
GET UP, BRUSH YOURSELF OFF, AND
TRY AGAIN.
BUT YOU HAVE TO EARN RESPECT TO
WIN THE VOTE.
YOU ARE ONLY GOING TO DO THAT BY
MAKING A PERSUASIVE ARGUMENT,
NOT BY HAUGHTILY ASSUMING THAT